if you've ever looked at the scale of
the universe animation you might have
sumed out far enough to see
Gomez's hamburger it is a quarter of a
Lightyear in size and nine hundred light
years away named after the man who first
saw this picture of it in 1985 Gomez's
hamburger is a proto planetary disc it
is the dust and debris left over after a
star has newly formed and begun to burn
hydrogen in its core this cosmic debris
is the material that eventually coalesce
into planets asteroids and comets around
the star what we are looking at is the
neighborhood of a baby star just sitting
down for a long life on the main
sequence this baby star at the heart of
the hamburger is probably somewhere in
the range of two to three times the mass
of our Sun we can't rule out the
possibility that it is two stars a
binary pair circling each other in the
middle the hamburger we see is
relatively cool gas and dust rotating
around the central star the brighter
parts the bands are relatively thinner
gases at higher temperatures glowing
from the energy released by the star and
all this rotation and friction
astronomers have also found a blob of
material inside the patty that could be
an emerging planet several times the
mass of Jupiter a planetary system
forming far away following the same
rules that led to our own solar system